SCP-682 VS D-3654.
Could a D-Class with an equally pessimistic
and misanthropic worldview as SCP-682 make
the perfect pacifying playmate?
The Foundation decided to send in the most
hateful D-Class they could find to have a
chat with SCP-682.
Strangely, 682 never tried to kill this D-Class,
they instead just chatted for a few minutes
about their incredibly low opinions on humanity,
while researchers listened from the sidelines.
Turns out that 682’s takes were too spicy
for even D-3654, as after under five minutes
of listening to 682 ranting, he slipped into
a catatonic state and died.
The researchers who were listening in also
needed to be treated for severe, violent depression.